[Music]
drinking and driving has been a long
standing issue here in the valley
county announced a new coalition today
that includes uber and the group mothers
against drunk driving hector mejia live
from clark county government center with
their message ahead of this very busy
weekend hector
hey their world leaders just want people
to go ahead and make a plan if they're
thinking about drinking and driving
ahead of this busy weekend the big game
weekend
new signs are going up across clark
county if you drink don't drive decide
to ride make the plan before you go out
for the evening decide to ride decide
what your plan is going to be the hope
is for people to see billboard signs at
local restaurants across town and
remember to make the right choice clark
county announced the new prevention
campaign ahead of a busy sports weekend
the organization mothers against drunk
driving says it's still the leading
killer on america's roads national
president alex oate was a teenager when
she survived a boat crash caused by a
drunk driver he hit me from the side
going more than 60 miles per hour
threw me off the jet ski i landed face
down in the water and the boat landed on
top of my body
i sustained many severe life-threatening
and life-long injuries from head to toe
including a traumatic brain injury
a shattered jaw a broken neck and the
loss of my right leg the campaign will
run through st patrick's day it was put
together by the newly created clark
county office of traffic safety which
also brought out the brewery and heiser
bush and uber as partners
the last year was the deadliest in 14
years with
235 traffic fatalities in clark county
the top causes were speeding and
impairment reporting live outside the
clark county government center hector
mejia live local now